cuál es la longitud del arco a veces el
arco a veces este arco de aquí nos dan
tres puntos para definir el arco si nos
dijeran el arco hace sería ambiguo
porque hay dos arcos hace podría ser
este arco de aquí o este arco de acá
cuando nos dicen b ya no queda duda de a
cual arco se refieren va de a ave hace
la tercera letra resuelve la ambigüedad
de a cuál arco nos referimos lo primero
que tenemos que pensar es en la
circunferencia de todo el círculo y
luego preguntarnos qué fracción de toda
la circunferencia es este arco la pista
aquí es que si tenemos toda la
circunferencia serían 360 grados y el
arco tiene 135 grados de esos 360 grados
pensemos primero en la circunferencia la
circunferencia es igual a 2 por pi por
radio nos dicen que el radio es de 3
centímetros así que la circunferencia es
igual a 2 por pi por 3 centímetros
o 2 por 36 por pi por lo que es 6
centímetros ahora sí vemos las opciones
de aquí sabemos que la circunferencia
completa del círculo es 6 centímetros
recordemos que pies 3.14 159 por lo que
esto va a ser un poco más grande que a
18 o 19 centímetros y si toda la
circunferencia mide más o menos 18 o 19
centímetros este arco es sólo una
fracción de toda la circunferencia y al
ver las opciones vemos que estas dos son
demasiado grandes pero veamos si podemos
encontrar la respuesta correcta la
circunferencia completa mide seis
centímetros pero este arco no es la
circunferencia completa sólo comprende
135 grados de los 360 grados de toda la
circunferencia así que podemos decir que
es 135 360 bosch de toda la
circunferencia recuerden que para dar
toda la vuelta tenemos 360 grados
mientras que este ángulo de este arco
mide 135 grados el ángulo suspendido
por este arco el arco mide 130 y 5 360
bosch de toda la circunferencia por lo
que lo multiplicamos por 6 por 10
centímetros vamos a tratar de
simplificar un poco esto dividimos el
numerador y el denominador entre 66
entre 6 es 1 360 entre 660 y si
dividimos 135 entre 5 tenemos 27 si 100
entre 5 es 20 y 35 dividido entre 57 por
lo que esto es 27 y esto de abajo será
12 que es 60 entre 5 y ahora podemos
dividir el numerador y el denominador
entre 3 27 entre 39 y 12 entre 13 es 4
nos quedan nueve cuartos por pi
centímetros lo escribimos o podemos
multiplicar el numerador por pin que es
nueve pi entre cuatro centímetros ahora
vemos las opciones y encontramos este
número en la segunda opción justo aquí